there's one nurse that i work with who
is seven months pregnant and this nurse
actually wants the vaccine she said i
want the vaccine i'll get the vaccine
just wait until i have my baby and i
will come back vaccinated and she was
forced to resign because they said no
at seven months pregnant this is someone
who actually wanted it and they're
holding the line and says no you're not
gonna be here come september 27th and
she resigned in lieu of being fired so
she can keep some benefits there but she
was forced out
i'm dave rubin and we're doing something
a little different today you know i've
been telling you guys that my inbox is
absolutely blowing up from people
reaching out to me about losing their
jobs or potentially losing their jobs
because of these vaccine mandates i'm
hearing from people in the health care
field i'm hearing from airline workers
people just across the economy across
the country
and i wanted to start interviewing a
couple of the people that are speaking
out against this
and i saw a tweet from this guy that i'm
about to introduce to you he is a
frontline er nurse former emt and
current congressional candidate in new
york's third district kevin cerdy
welcome to the reuben report
uh thank you so much for having me it's
honored to be here kevin i mentioned to
you right before we started new york's
third district i'm homegrown scioscia
man that means my parents are in what
could potentially be your district
uh what do you what do you want people
to know about you and why you're running
before we get to the specifics on
vaccines and all that
yeah so i'm running to really bring back
representation to the district and as a
congressman your title is representative
and i feel they have completely lost
sight of that and a lot of them are
running for you know keep themselves in
office and they run for the title and
the position of congressmen and they've
completely lost sight of what their job
really is and that's to represent the
people that voted them in and i'm
running on a term limits uh platform as
well which will limit that uh
availability to turn it into a career
now because i see congress as a service
to your country it's not a career to get
yourself rich okay so i just mentioned
my inbox is just crazy with people
reaching out to me wanting their stories
to be heard just telling me about all
sorts of awful things having to make the
choice between basically being fired or
going against their conscience
related to the vaccines but i saw a
tweet from you this is why i reached out
to you specifically
you sent this just a couple days ago i'm
an er nurse on long island i'm
pro-vaccine and anti-mandate
in my department four nurses either
resigned or will be fired due to the
mandates 24 administrators have been
fired another five
were forced against their will to get
the shot this mandate will destroy
hospitals okay so that's what's
happening to you in long island
obviously this is close to my heart um
well first do you mind if i ask what
hospital
uh i work for uh north hall with larger
hospitals
long island gotcha so
uh now that in mind we also have the the
governor of new york who nobody voted
for uh who in essence is firing 83 000
health care workers the people we were
told are the heroes they are going to be
replaced by the national guard if they
so choose not to get the vaccine so i'll
let you unpack that tweet but but to
start you're saying you're pro vaccine
your anti-mandate so do you want to
clean that up a little bit
absolutely and i myself i'm vaccinated i
got both my shots and my family got
their shots all my friends got it and i
think the vaccine does help limit the
symptoms of covet if you get it so it
does prevent icu stays it does work the
problem is it doesn't prevent you from
spreading the virus so the vaccine that
i got it is a risk or any vaccine we
take any medicine any medical procedure
there's always risks to it and
understanding those risks i got the
vaccine and i would encourage you people
to get the vaccine however
it's not a perfect vaccine yet this
thing cannot
stop transmission it can't stop you from
getting coveted which the cdc also just
said the other day
we can't be firing people
that choose not to get the vaccine uh
thankfully my wife was pregnant uh
during this and we chose not to get her
the vaccine while she was pregnant after
she gave birth we gave her the vaccine
but what if my wife was a nurse
my wife would be forced to be either get
the vaccine while you're pregnant or
fired and thankfully at the time we had
the opportunity of that choice and that
choice is not being offered today so i'm
pro-vaccine i just don't think anybody
should be fired if they think they don't
want the vaccine at this time you know
bizarrely on the pregnancy front you may
have seen the head of the cdc wilinsky
just a couple days ago saying oh it's
completely fine for pregnant women and
for breastfeeding women etc etc except
there's simply no way they could have
that data yet
it's too soon if we look at following
the science we're all scientists we have
degrees we've been doing this for over
20 years
data takes time this has only been you
know six eight months some of these
women that have had the vaccine and
given birth it's not long enough for us
to see the effects of what's happening
and there have been so many fda approved
drugs and treatments in the past that
we're realizing now are not safe and
they have recalls and it's just too soon
to be mandated it's got to be a choice
at this point when you mention some of
the nurses and administrators that you
know that now are either being forced to
step down or ultimately will be fired or
in essence they're furloughed so you
just you don't have to go to work but
you don't get paid so you're fired by
any reasonable estimation
what have their um
rationalities been as to why they're not
getting vaccinated
it ranges uh there's one nurse that i
work with who is seven months pregnant
and this nurse actually wants the
vaccine she said i want the vaccine i'll
get the vaccine just wait until i have
my baby and i will come back vaccinated
and she was forced to resign because
they said no
that's seven months pregnant this is
someone who actually wanted it and
they're holding the line and says no
you're not going to be here come
september 27th and she resigned in lieu
of being fired so she can keep some
benefits there but she was forced out we
have another great colleague of mine
who's in her 30s she's had a stroke
already she's blind in one eye had open
heart surgery and we know that there is
a very small risk but the risk is there
of blood clots with the vaccine and she
said i'm not taking that risk i'm
already blind in one eye i don't want to
be blind in another eye if i get this
clot and i'm predispositioned to have a
stroke this is somebody who's a nurse
she knows what she's talking about and
she was fired
many of others on religious beliefs and
others who just don't know they've had
covet they have the antibodies and the
whole purpose to get the vaccine is to
give you antibodies so we're a little
confused if you already have natural
antibodies why are you giving me another
shot to have antibodies and then
requiring me to get multiple boosters so
have you guys yeah have you brought that
starting have you guys brought that up
with administrators i mean i get that
sort of it's just going down the chain
and everyone's just like well they told
me to do it and you told me to do it
we're going to do it but when you bring
that up about the natural antibody thing
which nobody seems to want to discuss
you know fouchy and the head of the cdc
and everything else what are the
administrators saying to you guys
the administrators are saying they're
following the cdc protocol and they're
not going back to us with the science
that we know that they have you know a
lot of these administrators are doctors
and nurses and this isn't a nursing
thing this is spread out to pharmacists
and doctors and nurses it's all
throughout health care of multiple
people wanting the vaccine or not
wanting it and the majority of them have
already had covet they've tested
positive through blood work that they
have antibodies
and they're being told no you still have
to get the shot and that's what we're
really fighting and i'm trying to
represent a whole group here because
it doesn't make sense if we're giving
you a shot to give you antibodies but
you already have antibodies which has
also been proven to be more likely at uh
stopping you from getting the virus if
you have natural antibodies than the
synthetic ones from the vaccine
when you hear
sort of the trusted quote unquote
trusted class and the media people talk
about covid yet not bring up natural
antibodies not bring up some of the
other uh remedies for kovid you know
we're not allowed to talk about some of
this stuff it's like
what are you guys thinking like are you
shocked that suddenly medicine is not
allowed to be talked about that certain
remedies are not allowed to be talked
about
well any government should employ they
should not be
dictating how medicine should work you
know where people they've gone to
medical school we've gone to nursing
school we've gone to pharmacy school we
know what we're talking about we know
how to treat this
they should not be telling us what we
should be doing what we can't be doing
and it's not based on science we're not
seeing that there's any data behind this
so we can only allude that this is some
kind of a power grab or there's money
behind it there's some other reason
because it's not the science we're
trying to follow the science of it and
they're telling us not to if i would
have said to you a year ago at the
height of kovid you know let's say or
even a little more than a year ago a
year and a half ago it's it's now may of
2020 something like that if i would have
said to you uh you know in a year and a
half from now uh half of your friends
and colleagues are going to be stepping
down or forced out or fired uh because
they didn't take a vaccine what do you
think you would have said when at that
time you guys were the greatest heroes
of all time
i probably would have left
and said there's no way that's possible
to happen when we were in this the thick
of it we didn't have enough ppe to wear
and mine myself was wearing the same
mask for weeks on ends and before covid
that mask was supposed to be worn one
patient at a time you wear it you take
it off you throw it in garbage you get a
new one and we were wearing this for
weeks at the same time i haven't had one
of the straps break on a mask and was
told just tie it together so we went
through a lot sacrifice and it's a risk
that we all knew we were taking we were
in health care that's what we do we're
first responders and any of us would do
it again immediately without any
hesitation and we're still doing we're
still treating covet patients many
vaccinated covenant patients as well
and for them to say you're going to be
fired for not getting a vaccine after
everything we just went through it it's
mind boggling and it
where i'm really sticking on why this
doesn't make sense because we are in a
healthcare pandemic
we are in a national nursing shortage
right now currently today before a lot
of people even being fired and
terminated i get text messages every
single day all across long island
begging for overtime come in we need
help 250 extra to come in
if you lose just one or two providers
you are going to devastate that
department we're already short staffed
so if you're going to fire more people i
don't understand how that's better
because me personally i'd much rather
get treated by an unvaccinated person
with antibodies than being treated by
nobody at all and there's going to be a
time you're going to come to that
hospital and your care is going to be
delayed because there are not going to
be enough people that care for you right
and by the way do we even have any
numbers or do you know of any numbers of
you know at the peak of this thing
unvaccinated healthcare workers that
were somehow infecting people at
hospitals or have they done any studies
on that that you know of
not to my knowledge and i highly doubt
it and a lot of us got covered during
the piece of it right you know you're
out for two three weeks and you're fine
you're right back yes it was devastating
a lot of people did die you know i held
the hands of dying patients it was a lot
you know to deal with in the hospitals
but there's a high survivability rate
personally in one of the hospital
systems you know we did lose you know a
few healthcare workers but the majority
of them were fine and if they got covert
they got the antibodies and they're
still working currently today
why are we forcing this vaccine on them
even though we think the vaccine does
work and it limits your symptoms but a
lot of these people have very legitimate
reasons like i spoke about to not get
this vaccine why are we firing these
people it just doesn't make sense that
we need health care professionals right
now more than ever yeah for short stuff
it doesn't make sense for some of my
audience that may be hesitant and as i
have said completely from the beginning
the entire time it's i believe the same
position you're taking which is that you
have to make the right choice for
yourself and you should consult with
your doctor and your age and your health
and your diet and all of those things
should matter if someone's hesitant do
you have a recommendation on which one
they should take or just anything on
that side of things
a be more of a conversation between them
and their doctor there hasn't really
been too much to prove one's better than
the other personally i had uh moderna uh
it's the two uh shots that i got my
family got that one and we got that one
because that's what they offered that
day uh if they were offering fives i
would have gotten the fives of one uh so
that's all up to interpersonal choice
what of your colleagues that are now
stepping down or being furloughed etc uh
do they know what they're gonna do with
their lives i mean most people don't
have
uh you know months in in salary just
waiting in the bank and you know you
didn't think you were going to step away
from a career and here we are
it's very stressful a lot of them have
kids too uh you know there's one nurse
she's a single mom been nursed for quite
a few years in the er and she very
reluctantly got the vaccine
against her will she that did not want
this at all she's very distressed
because she's already gotten the first
shot she goes i can't lose my job i'm a
single mom if i lose my job i can't
afford my house or to feed my kid i
don't have a choice here and that's just
horrible to do someone's just sacrificed
their whole last year working overtime
coming in extra you know we used to get
undressed outside of our house i
personally quarantined two weeks away
from my family in the beginnings i
didn't know if i would bring this home
and now this is someone that wants to
care for a child and she doesn't have
another option so she was forced to get
that vaccine
is there anything else you want people
to know we're going to do a whole series
of these shows i'm going to try to talk
to people in all sorts of different
industries and i just think it's
important that people realize what's
actually happening on the ground is
there anything that we missed here that
you want to get out yeah just to uh you
know if you do want to find more
information on my website
certyforcongress.com
s-u-r-d-i for congress.com a ton of
information on there you can follow and
one note about the governor's using the
national guard this is a horrible policy
decision god bless the people in the
national guard they're absolutely heroes
they do a ton of great work for us but
if we're gonna activate the medical
people from the national guard these are
doctors nurses pharmacists and they're
working right now
in hospitals the national guard is a
part-time military position
with what's going to happen is when the
guard is activated you're going to pull
these full-time doctors and nurses that
are working at other hospitals today
away from their home hospital and put
them in other hospitals so we're just
going to make staffing shorter all
around by deploying the national guard
and i don't know if a lot of people know
that
the national guard has a horrible policy
decision
amongst a lot of other horrible ones
it's not going to solve the problem it's
actually going to make it a lot worse
are you hopeful that enough people will
hear the message that you're trying to
get out there that enough people will
come around and be like oh yeah maybe my
own personal choice is more important
than what the government demands that i
do like do you sense that something's
moving there that there's momentum there
there are a lot of people uh you know a
big hope is the governor comes to her
senses and resends the order you know
we've seen this possible i don't think
so it's my hope uh alabama they
rescinded it uh there are some places
that are um you know
they're not doing it you know they kind
of told uh the state you know we're just
we're not gonna do this and we're hoping
they stand their ground and they
continue to say this is my choice i have
antibodies i don't have antibodies but
you can't force something that is this
new uh you know a lot of people argue
that you know the vaccine is not new the
research has been there and i fully
agree the research has been there but
they haven't used it on humans this is a
new thing that's being actually used
we're still in a trial phase and you
know i was fine getting the shot you
know i looked at the research and the
data and i took the acknowledged risk to
get it that was my choice it was our
choice and my wife didn't get the
vaccine while she was pregnant don't
take the choice out of people especially
the people that are fighting on the
front lines to protect their community
they're putting themselves and their
families at risk they still want to work
they still want to care for you and if
you got the vaccine you can still spread
the virus
so why is it that we're firing people
and we're fighting for it just give them
a test
i'd much rather look get test every
airplay when we come into work give us
all a test and that way we know for sure
we don't have covert that day and we
won't spread the patient i think every
healthcare worker can get behind that um
you know the flu vaccine was mandated
and they said well if you don't want the
flu vaccine wear a mask there's always
been another option that's all we're
asking for give us a test let us know we
absolutely don't have it and that's
actually the safest thing you can do uh
that's not being happen this is a power
grab it feels like a punishment of some
sort um and it's just not the right
thing to do and patients are going to
suffer which is why i'm standing this
line i can't have this affect patient
care
kevin we the people stand with you guys
it's surdy for congress.com we're going
to link to it right down below and keep
new york three especially sias it's safe
that's that's billy joel country over
there
please you know give us your support um
there's a place to donate on the website
unfortunately you know politics does
require money to get the message out
it's a sad part uh hopefully when i'm in
congress i can try to fix that uh but
send a donation help us get that message
out there and please look for your votes
and if there's anything uh you need
please reach out contact me all my
information is on the website i'd love
to speak with you individually
kevin cerdy thanks so much if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell